this is the jocko unraveling podcast
episode 2 with daryl cooper and me
jocko willink i know that the last
episode
you know we wrapped up with a
pretty harrowing account and
you kind of said well we'll move on to
other things but
i got to keep us there for one more um
account here
it goes like this horror in saddam's
iraq takes endless forms
in 1987 1988 iraqi air force helicopters
sprayed scores of
kurdish villages with a combination of
chemical weapons including mustard gas
sarin and vx a deadly nerve agent
scores of thousands of kurds
most of them women and children died
horrible deaths
of those who survived many were left
blind or sterile or crippled
with agonizing lung damage
but most of the kurds slaughtered in
that season of mass murder
were not gassed but rounded up and
gunned down
into mass graves those victims
were mostly men and boys and their
bodies have never been recovered
in one village near kirkuk
after the males were taken to be killed
the women and small children were
crammed into trucks
and taken to a prison
one survivor salma aziz baban
described the ordeal to journalist
jeffrey goldberg
who reported on saddam's war against the
kurds
in the new yorker in march
more than 2 000 women and children were
crammed into a room and given nothing to
eat
when some starved to death the iraqi
guards
demanded that the body be passed
to them through a window
in the door aziz's
six-year-old son grew very sick
she says he knew he was dying
there was no medicine or doctor he
started to cry so much
he died in his mother's lap
i was screaming and crying she told
goldberg
we gave them the body
it was passed outside and the soldiers
took it
soon after she pushed her way to the
window to see if her child had been
taken for burial
she saw 20 dogs roaming in the field
where the dead bodies had been dumped
she said i looked outside and saw the
legs and hands of my son in the mouths
of the dogs
the dogs were eating my son
then i lost my mind
and that is from an article called
saddam's
shop of horrors written by jeff jacoby
and i was from the boston globe in uh
2002.
so you know that's 2002
right it's not like it's not like we
didn't
know that this stuff was happening
right we didn't invade until 2003 this
is 2002. we know what's going on in
there
so where does that kind of um
where's that guy come from how much you
know about his origin story
i know pretty yeah decent amount i mean
it's a it's a super villain origin story
in some way
completely um you know he his father and
brother die of cancer while his mother's
pregnant
his mother is so depressed that she
tries to abort saddam but he survives
and so she just abandons him and he goes
to stay with an uncle for a while
he eventually comes back to his mother
after she remarries but the stepfather
just abuses him terribly and so he flees
and
goes back it's like well that's how you
start that's that's those are those are
the
opening ingredients for how you get a
guy like this but
i think it's important to remember too
like the stuff you're reading right
there
all this stuff that happened one guy
does not do that
one person cannot do that hitler can't
commit the holocaust by himself
you know and saddam could not create
that terror state all by himself either
yes um i'll tell you what
man
leadership is the most important thing
on the battlefield and it's guys like
hitler and guys like saddam the man they
set the conditions
and then what's really scary is
you know as we see in when atrocities
take place
right sure it's not it's not that leader
it doesn't take it doesn't take much
it doesn't take much to
to to lead people down this road like
all the all the
all the you know you want to throw it
out there that people are
you know naturally benevolent and
they're naturally people want to help
each other i get it and i
i i know that that is a
thing to that you can convince yourself
of and it's probably right in many cases
in the right conditions uh you change
those conditions
and it's it's it's not a it's not a
stretch
it doesn't take as much as you would
hope it takes
to lead people down this path it just
that's the that's the horrible truth and
that's why we have to be
so aware of it that's why we have to
understand it you know when we did the
when we did the podcast on the milai
massacre
and the sand creek massacre and we we
went through those but when i did milai
on my podcast
you know those were normal people yeah
that was a that was a cross-section of
america
now one of those and i had this
conversation with jordan peterson as
well which was
i had told an army group that they had
sadists in their platoon
like i said listen you got and i and
they were looking at me and i i talk to
people a lot i can read a crowd
and they were looking at me
as if i was you know a little bit crazy
and maybe just you know trying to be
extreme or whatever and
i i'm looking back at them and i'm
thinking they don't believe me right now
they don't believe me they think i'm
wrong or they don't believe me or this
is just hyperbole and
no no and then so i said oh wait wait a
second you guys are looking at me like i
don't know what i'm talking about here
like you're
like you're gonna be in a platoon and
this was actually um young you know uh
uh officers on the way to being
commissioned so
i wasn't officer candidates or cadets
i said you're looking at me like i don't
know what i'm talking about right now
and and i said let me let me ask you
this if
i'm wrong then how did how did milai
unfold how did that happen
if if you've got a platoon or a company
and there's 150 guys there's no bad
apples in there how does that happen
that one that one company just happened
to get all the bad guys every bet
and you know when i when i i actually
drilled
down a little bit with jordan peterson
and i said hey you know this is what i
told these army guys
i said i told them in a platoon they got
a sadist in there
am i right and i think i think i said
murderer too
you know which i don't know what the i
don't know what how you draw that line
but he said well he said how many people
in the platoon i said 40
and he goes oh yeah you're good you're
you're you're in
especially because there's a whole
chunk of civilization that just don't go
in the military right and that chunk
that just doesn't want to go in the
military
almost none of that mercedes right you
as soon as you're in the military you
have a higher percentage
of you know what do you what are you
signing up for i'm signing up to shoot
people and kill people that's what i'm
signing up to so there's a there's a
whole element that's already gone so
1 out of 40 it's pretty pretty pretty
nice pretty generous
and so as we talk about this it's like
yes
i get it that it wasn't all saddam
clearly but man you you
he absolutely set the conditions for
this yeah
and that was the other thing interesting
the thing about the milan massacre is
that
it was one officer you know thompson who
had flown in saw it was happening flaw
back flew back to headquarters said
these guys are murdering people
just tell you need to stop it and the
the commanding officer gets on the horn
and says
hey stop killing people and they were
like okay they stopped like
instantly yeah it's instantly you
wouldn't believe if you saw it in a
movie you wouldn't believe it like
waking up from a dream you wouldn't
believe it if you saw a movie oh they
just gonna stop now
no that's what happened they got told no
and they stopped i wish i would have
brought i read an account by a guy who
was a member of isis
and he had this he had done it all
sex slavery killing i mean everything
and he sort of he describes it as like
waking up from a dream he's in the
middle of massacring a village
of an assault on a village and he snaps
out of it and goes what
am i doing and he found his way out of
it after that he talks about this stuff
now i have to
i'll bring some of that in tomorrow um
and you wonder like okay that's a guy
who's capable of waking up and saying
what am i doing
that's the same guy who was he's raped
he has murdered children
with conviction doing it with conviction
you know um we're complex creatures
and we're very adaptable creatures and
we can adapt to whatever environment we
find ourselves in
and i think one of the things that you
know we have certain
models that we use for thinking about
other people's behavior and we think
about
you know we think about like the french
resistance in germany right
or the partisans out in the east when
when germany overran them
we think well they didn't give up right
they just kept fighting and they
resisted the power
okay what if what if it's over hitler
won because that's what happened in iraq
hitler won it's over and now you've got
to adapt yourself
to that society because nobody's coming
to save you
you know not until 2003 at least i mean
that's that's it
and you got to figure out how to survive
in a place where
um you don't just get killed for treason
you get killed because you know
somebody's having a paranoid attack
and that's it or or somebody needs to
send a message to a bunch of other
people it's got nothing to do with you
you got to figure out how to navigate
that
people can become very different
creatures than
they kind of naturally devolve into when
they live in vermont
you know um i've seen some pretty
devolved creatures up in vermont
yeah no it's uh actually vermont's
probably a place where you wouldn't
evolve you'd get better you become a
better person up there in the in the
woods
in the sticks so let's go back to saddam
yeah where were we at have you ever seen
the video
it's an amazing video the video um when
he
at the meet at the bathurst meeting
where he took power yeah yeah yeah yeah
it is i tell every i tell everybody to
watch it
and watch him and so for the people who
haven't seen it
um there's like a nine minute version
out there kind of cuts it short you can
go see the thing but
um he's got all so he's taken over
right from general kasim who's the guy
before him and he's taken power and he
calls all the bathurst party leaders and
senior
senior membership into this assembly
hall
and they're you know some people are
talking everything saddam strides up and
he is i mean you watch him and he is
just like either a great actor or what
he is confident he is just striding up
there with an arrogant pose
and he starts speaking about the
traitors that are out there and all the
people that are besetting the country of
iraq and the party and blah blah blah
and people are like
yeah okay and he reaches down and just
slowly pulls this
big long cigar out of his pocket and
lights it
and he's on there on stage and he starts
smoking this cigar and he just starts
saying if i call your name stand up and
go to the back of the room
and people are kind of start to look
around at each other he's planned all
this so he's having it filmed
and he knows who's going to be called so
like the camera will go to some of them
sometimes
and as he's calling his names people are
kind of looking like what is going on
they know what's going on but
they're just they're they don't know
what to do and so they get up and they
head to the back where the guards are
and finally one guy goes stands up and
he says wait why did you call me i
didn't do anything i didn't do anything
and saddam just says
if i call your name please stand up and
go to the back with the guards
and the guy just goes back and people go
back and
people are starting to look at each
other and realizing like what's
happening here
and uh that these guys are being called
back to go be executed
and then afterwards he up he says a few
words
and all of a sudden the people just
break out long live saddam
long live saddam and they're all giving
him like a big standing ovation
because what else are you going to do in
that situation right and
uh you know this is a guy who was in
power for over
you know for almost 30 years for 25
years and he had a long long period of
time
to find exactly the people
to put into positions who were going to
do exactly what he needed him to do to
keep control of that
of that society and the rest of the
people there had to figure out how to
survive under that
i mean from uh the moment saddam
takes power he is at war essentially
you know 1979 he takes power and he's at
war with iraq
next uh with iran the next year and
it's a war that kind of gets lost today
a lot of people just slide right past it
i mean it was one of the it was probably
the worst war in the second half of the
20th century in a lot of ways
at least the way it was fought for sure
brutal over a million killed
you know devolving to a point where the
two sides are just
launching you know uh
ballistic missiles at each other's
cities just population centers
indiscriminately just launching them at
each other
you know chemical weapons being used on
population
centers purely to terrorize you know to
let people know that
you better not rise up
and uh this at this point
saddam's pretty a pretty secular leader
yeah
i mean this isn't a guy that's out you
know touting islam as
uh as the rule of law around iraq
he would stay that way till the 90s yeah
yeah um the baptist party is a secular
kind of socialist
pan-arab arab nationalist party
and um you know that's why one of the
things i think people really
really lose a little bit today is they
think that
like america and the middle east that
we've just been over there pulling the
strings like the puppet masters
from all the way back like from 1776 or
something that's what we've been doing
when you know centcom wasn't even stood
up until 1983.
you know the iran iraq war been going on
for three years this is 10 years after
the oil crisis and
central command's not even stood up and
i remember after the uss stark got hit
the frigate got hit by a cruise missile
in 1987
even in 1987 the response to that from a
lot of the navy brass was why are we
over there
what are we what are we doing here you
know we were very much reacting to
events
and we didn't know a lot about who these
people were you know
uh when somebody like saddam comes along
he seems
like a secular nationalist type leader
he's got some worrying tendencies but
he's only been around a year
and meanwhile we've got the iranians
over here
who just took over with like an extreme
islamist revolution
overran our embassy took a bunch of our
people hostage and
are are starting to act out in some
pretty extreme ways and so that's the
context that saddam comes into the
picture
and all of a sudden he wants to fight
with iran he's got a big soviet army
you know the iranians unfortunately have
a pretty well-equipped military as well
because we were the
shah's you know we were his friend
before that and so they took possess we
had just in the last few years before
1979 had sold him a bunch of f-15s and a
bunch of
just great aircraft and it gave saddam
fits in the war because of that but i
mean they had a pretty well equipped
army
you know we had been equipping iran as
an ally for years
and now you have this revolutionary
government yeah this is when you see the
pictures of iran in 1974 and the women
are wearing mini skirts out in town and
it looks like a metropolitan
western country yep and i you know it's
one of the reasons that
a lot of people get on my case because i
tend to give i tend to give saudi arabia
a little bit more of a break than a lot
of people i know and the reason i do it
though
is as opposed to a place like iran
where iran was a certain way you know
where women were free
and it was relatively modern place and
then they had this revolution that said
nope no more of that
and presumably a lot of those people who
were enjoying their lives back in the
day
still live there and now they have to
live under this regressive you know in
this regressive manner
saudi arabia however however they look
to us
obviously it's not acceptable and you
know according to
the way we do business they're as
liberal now as they've ever been
you know it's a slow long project but
it's not like they were a certain way
and then they got taken over by these
crazy islamists and
you know uh iran's not that way iran was
a relatively free and open
secular country you know where women
were free and uh so
all of a sudden you get this revolution
and the revolutionary part's important
right because it's not just a government
that's kind of hostile now
and maybe is doing things passing laws
social social
laws and stuff that we don't like it's a
rev it considers itself a revolutionary
state like the soviet union did so it's
not just an enemy country it's a
revolutionary movement
and they're eyeing the rest of the
muslim world you know it's why they
established hezbollah and lebanon it's
why now they're still trying to
establish
an iraqi version of that like to this
day is it's built into their system into
their ideology that this is an
expansionist thing
there's a larger project so it doesn't
just involve them
it involves the rest of the muslim world
so that's very worrying to us in 1979
they've still got our people you know
that they're holding captive from the
embassy saddam comes along
he starts fighting with these people and
of course at first we're kind of like
all right
maybe this guy's all right let's see how
this plays out right he hasn't done all
the things he's gonna do yet
he's not a nice guy we know that um
but we don't have the whole story and we
kind of have some hope and so
we start out in the iran-iraq war and
you know we're kind of hoping that maybe
he can
who knows maybe create enough stress on
the iranian regime that they flip back
over or something like that
and you're also you're also looking at
the situation you got a leader coming
into power
and you don't really you know like you
said you know he's bad
but you kind of think well he's stepping
into power he's going to want influence
he's going to need what we have we can
how can we how can we
how can we bring them along how can we
bring them onto our our team yeah
yeah that was definitely the thinking
and you know we didn't know who we were
dealing
with we did not recognize the the level
of
of beasts that we were dealing with with
saddam and i think by the end of the 80s
we had a pretty good idea that that was
the case
because we'd end up at war with him
ourselves shortly after that
i mean the iranians you know again like
they they seemed very dangerous at the
time this is a big country
large population a well-equipped
military
um with an expansionist foreign policy
and when they were fighting iraq
you know these are people who are who
are who are sending human waves of
teenagers across minefields to clear
them
with no weapons just sending human waves
of kids across
minefields to clear them out um this is
this was a regime that looked very very
dangerous and they were dangerous
um we just maybe you know we allowed
ourselves to get sucked into some
illusions about
you know how how controllable saddam
hussein was that's for sure
when uh yeah i think uh there's a lot of
there's a lot we don't know about the
casualties in the iran iraq war but most
estimates have it between 800 000 and a
million people
it's a big war it's a big conventional
war the battle of basra
toward the end of it i think was the
biggest battle since
the second world war if i'm not mistaken
maybe since one of the one of the korean
war
korean wars battles but um
i think uh 65
000 iranians and 25 000 iraqis were
killed
i mean it's a big battle that's a big
battle um
you know in a set piece battle we're
just not used to those kind of things
anymore there's a lot of trench warfare
going on
and they are just this is a war of
attrition i mean literally the
i mean they're at the point toward the
end where their manpower is depleted and
they're just
launching studs at each other's cities
you know and
um it's a brutal thing and uh
that ends in 1988
a month before that is when uss vintenz
shot down that iranian airliner
but as the iranians now know from their
recent experience
things happen yeah i brought that up uh
i was surprised it wasn't brought up
more
um after this recent incident you know
and this is again you know when you
start talking about the
the theme of having a thread tie back to
the but yeah the vincennes
uh shot down an iranian airliner
however many souls were on board you
know hundreds or 150 or whatever that
number is
yeah i mean so it's a massive loss of
life
and you know we very
very actually very similar circumstances
when you pick that apart you know the
the iranian shooting down the airline
iranian shoot down of the airline was it
was
so similar like the panic buttons going
off
you know they there's there's
uncertainty going on
i remember i had some people that i knew
not military people who
um when the iranians shot down that
airliner they were kind of being like oh
something like that doesn't happen by
mistake i'm like no totally yes it
totally happens by mistake
very very easy you don't know who's
running that thing they've never been in
combat before
you know that the person running that
air defense battery has never been in
combat they've never had a situation
where it counted
and uh yeah they're in a situation where
they're probably expecting to be hard
you're all spun up you're waiting to get
attacked by the americans
and all of a sudden you know you're
you're
you know you and i can picture this
you're probably actually you better than
me because you
were in the uh in the
combat information center is that it
what's the cic yeah that's it
so you're in that on a ship and there's
all of a sudden you know someone's going
all right we got it we're tracking we're
tracking an inbound
and there's that spin up of the voice
and
and now you got to make a decision you
got to make a decision
what we're going to do we see something
on the radar we're looking at it
we know we're vulnerable to attack right
now we're anticipating attack
oh where's it heading we're tracking oh
guess where it's heading for us
all right hey we need to take this thing
out this is a missile this is an attack
boom this is a
this could so easily happen it's
ridiculous actually how easy it could
happen
in 87 when the start got hit by an iraqi
cruise missile
two cruise missiles i think the um the
tao tactical action officer
and the commanding officer they got
disciplined for failing to defend their
ship
and i i gotta imagine i mean they're
sitting there like
is this really happening right now if i
hit fire am i gonna kill a bunch of
civilians like
that's a that's a worrying thing you
know and it's got to be a tough i've
never had to make any decision like that
obviously
and uh yeah it's a tough one i mean
especially if you're panda i have to
imagine that night
when the iranians launched those
missiles at us a few months ago
they must have just been sitting on pins
and needles bracing for impact
especially with trump you know you know
what that guy's gonna do and if he does
respond you know it's going to be
overwhelming and uh they had to have
been bracing for impact
i mean it up you know they called ahead
and everything supposedly but
i mean golly you just don't know and the
vincennes had had
similar like spin-ups going into that
shoot down
as well where it was that wasn't that
wasn't uh
again i'm not saying uh not making
excuses but
sitting here and i can understand how
that unfolds
i always bring up the fact that in
ramadi there was blue on blue
you know there was humvees that shot at
other humvees
yeah so so think about that you know
like humvee one of the most recognizable
vehicles
ever made which is solely used by the us
military
and i guess we had iraqis using at that
point as well but the enemy
was not driving around in humvees years
later isis was driving around in humvees
but
at that time there was no one driving
around in humvees
no enemy and and you know a young guy
paranoid and freaked out and scared and
you know sees a muzzle flash or sees
whatever and i'm gonna engage
that's what happens it's horrible
knowing that you know if you fail to act
then
the next second you might be dead and
you just gotta do it and it's the wrong
decision but
and yeah when you're dealing with
something like air defense you're not
looking at an aircraft up there you're
looking to blip on a radar screen
you know at an aircraft that's out of
visual range
and so saddam yeah we're talking about
saddam
this guy comes into power in 79 starts
executing people
starts terrorizing population
immediately goes to war with iran
has an eight-year-long war it's the
bloodiest war the second half of the
20th century
um just a brutal you know horrible war
that's fought with
incredibly brutal tactics uh that ends
in late 1988
and you would think that like maybe
saddam would want to kind of take a
breather
but it's not it's not what this guy's
about and it was kind of a draw
yes it came to a draw basically yeah no
neither side achieved any uh
you know any gains through it saddam was
the one who launched the war and he
didn't achieve any gains so you could
say he lost on that count but yeah
but yeah um yeah 19 that's late 1988
by early 1989 saddam is already telling
kuwait
so a lot of the other arab countries
worried about iran too so they were
financing saddam they were
loaning money things like that and
already by early 1989 saddam is telling
kuwait hey you're gonna have to forgive
that debt
because we were defending you two and
we're not paying that 65 billion dollars
and kuwait's not willing to do that they
say that we're we're not going to do it
saddam's like oh you're going to do it
and by the next summer summer in 1990
he's invading kuwait
so no rest for the weary right and he
does it in an unpredictable way um
i remember seeing an interview with
mubarak the egyptian president at the
time
long time egyptian president and we were
allies with mubarak
we knew him well and he was not just
allies with he was friends with saddam
hussein by this point he knew him
they would talk on the phone and uh
he called saddam on the phone and he
says what's going on here are you going
to invade kuwait
and saddam tells him no no i'm just
bluffing just don't worry about it
it's totally fine the next day he
invades kuwait
oh and so so actually here's what
happened there's something else in there
is mubarak comes and tells us that he
says hey he's bluffing don't worry about
it and so
our ambassador at the time gets called
in by saddam
and uh saddam wants to feel him out
right
see how we're doing with this whole
thing and our ambassador had just heard
from mubarak
he's bluffing don't worry about it don't
don't push him and so he says oh you
know
arab on arab like affairs that's not
really our business we're not we don't
really
i'm not invested in this and saddam goes
all right and the next day he invades
kuwait right so mubarak nobody had any
idea what was going on here i mean i
don't even know if
i i read that quote in the last episode
that he tells somebody one thing he
tells another person another thing
and then after that he does something
completely different that surprises he's
even surprises himself yeah and so maybe
it was something like that i mean he
you know it's it's not beyond him
just the mentality that you're dealing
with i mean you go you go in an
eight-year war
and by the way you're sitting in a place
in a country that's got these incredible
amount of natural resources i mean you
could
saddam hussein could have lived i'm
going to say like live like a king but
like he could have lived
because he did live like a king but he
could have lived like a peaceful king
and just had an incredible
oh yeah you know an incredible existence
especially with iran right there
threatening everybody we would have been
happy to make him the face of the arab
world we would have been happy to do it
so that's where you start you know
that's where you start to really
you know look when people are driven to
some sadistic
evil pathology in their life
because they don't really have a choice
like you go i kind of understand that
imagine even if you even if you're like
let's say you take power and just to set
everyone straight
you murder a bunch of people that you
think might rise up against you
and then you look around and now
everyone is just totally good to go
they're like they're
they're cheering for you and you go you
know what all right
hey we're good i'm going to ride this
out
i'm going to take advantage of this and
then maybe you're a little bit crazy
and you go you know what though i kind
of want to be you know that guy
so i'm going to start a war with with
you know with iran with my neighbor over
here
so you roll into that you get them you
know
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
your own people killed
you don't get what you want but you know
what you get you you finally end up with
a truce
everyone knows that you'll fight if
needed so now maybe you look around and
you go you know what
all right i've i've kind of established
myself
everybody knows not to mess with me um
i've got billions of dollars worth of
oil
i've got security because my you know my
my i've protected my borders i'm good
i'm good i'm gonna ride this one out i'm
gonna i'm gonna watch netflix and chill
right what kind of a person gets through
all that
and has the opportunity just to like do
to live a good life and says you know
what
man kuwait looks pretty tasty
that's a that's a that's a really
and i guess you could make the same you
know you could make the same argument
with hitler right you know i mean
how much is enough and how much is
enough
you know you're storming into czech
slovakia you're storming into poland
you've got
these great resources now you know what
russia england i'm going
that's like a different mentality yeah
and
yeah and after kuwait's military stands
down because they have no chance against
iraq
that guy now owns over 20 of the world's
oil
that guy right that's what we're looking
at and he's massing troops on the saudi
arabian border
which just down the eastern uh shore
over there is where the vast majority of
their oil is
and so that's that guy's now got this
place
and this is right after the cold war
right the soviet union's still around in
1990 but
the wall fell in 89 and america is kind
of
the big dog now everybody knows that and
george h.w bush is president
and he says this is kind of an
opportunity to show the world
you know what the american-led global
order is going to be
going to be like and um
he one of the things we got to remember
about this i think
this gets twisted up in our heads a
little bit now that the gulf war
was kind of you know because it went so
well and everything just kind of
because of the way the iraqi army fell
apart we were not sure about that going
in yeah for sure
so seaman recruit willink uh joined the
navy
shipped out september 13th 1990.
so you know we hadn't started yet so
there was still a lot of unknowns
and man i was fired up and i remember
and i'll have to try and find this at
some point in my life i remember hearing
they anticipate 40 000 casualties
in the first 48 hours yeah and i thought
man i'm gonna get i'm gonna get after it
you know i was i was fired up
and you know i just had a guy on um who
was
there for for the push-up he's in the
marine corps and
like 100 percent 100 percent
thought we thought or the u.s military
wasn't there but the guys that were on
the ground
there 100 thought we're going to get you
know there's going to be chemical
biological attacks that's what's going
to happen
mop level you know they're in and out of
their mop level suits all day long
putting the gas masks on put them away i
mean we 100
and so as soon as you start throwing
chemical and biological weapons into
this scenario
you're you're going to lose you're going
to lose a lot of guys i
i can't even it's the strength did you
ever have to put on
mop gear yeah
did it not like strike you as the
saddest
excuse for like something that's gonna
save your life
for instance on the like first of all
it's in two pieces right
so you've got like these pants on
they're not even they're not even
like a bib that would come up higher
they're just pants you put them on
over your regular pants there's a
drawstring
there's not a belt there's a drawstring
so you just pull this thing tight
and then you put a jacket on over your
upper body so there's
there's a big gap yeah like this is
going to save you is that what we're
saying and you got a maneuver in the
desert
yeah and that's all fine that's all like
take take all the maneuvering out of it
i'm just saying if you put me in that
suit
and you said okay i'm going to put you
expose you to chemical weapons now i'd
be like cool appreciate it i got a 20
chance of living and it's only if i can
run away quick enough i had no
faith in those suits and we had good
suits too like we had the good ones
i had this blower contraption that
when you put on your gas mask it would
it would give you it would it would send
positive airflow into your
into your into your uh mask so it was
like really nice
uh yeah so it's very strange there were
estimates um that had the first marines
you know the first marines just rampaged
through the iraqi army for sure when
they went up but there were estimates
going in saying they might lose 10 to 15
on the first on the first push there
were estimates that said we might lose
one out of five aircraft on the first
attack
and so we didn't you know the guys who
were planned the military guys colin
powell
general schwarzkopf these were these
were jos in vietnam
and so when we were looking at doing
this we were hesitant at first
for sure it started off with like george
bush was like we need to make statement
here but a lot of the military guys like
i've seen this movie
like i want clear political objectives
and more than that i want overwhelming
force
and gladly that's what bush gave him we
brought six carrier strike groups in
there
we brought the seventh corps down from
europe we brought the first marines and
the marine expeditionary force we had
arab allies we had a bunch
we came rolling deep well three hundred
thousand four hundred thousand
troops what was the number do you know
the number off the top of your head it
was over four hundred thousand when you
count the arab allies
and six carrier strike groups i mean we
hit it hard and i think that even our
own side didn't quite realize
how far we had come technologically now
saddam thought
this is some there's some lessons
learned on both sides that ended up
coming back to bite us
both um in the first iraq war saddam
thought this is a technological power
these americans are technicians they're
not
soldiers and um you know all their fancy
gear is not you can't win a war
and so we hit him watch this we hit him
hard we drive him out of kuwait but when
we didn't pursue him
he thought we were afraid to yeah you
know he thought we were afraid to go
pursue him and fight
and um i got to uh
i guess it must have been like 93 94.
i guess okay 94 94 when i was in kuwait
and you know we would we were going out
to the desert train but we went up the
highway of death
and like still there was littered yeah
there was vehicles
you know destroyed and man
you ever heard about the um again now
we're talking about it's not just saddam
but
there's there were there were maybe
you've heard the story
there were kuwaiti
there were there were places where they
had kuwaiti women
nine months later where they had these
orphaned kids because so many
kuwaiti women had been raped by the
by saddam's soldiers that they had these
orphans pretty much have you heard that
yeah yeah there's no there was no limits
there were all sorts of atrocities they
committed in kuwait
while they knew the whole world was
watching that's the crazy part about it
you know he had a level of arrogance and
i mean which led to a lot of bad
decision making on saddam hussein's part
um you know he thought he thought his
military was ready he thought we were
gonna
you know get a bloody nose like you know
if we tried to go after him and he
he blamed the loss on his general he had
a bunch of his generals executed
afterwards
he blamed that on his military
leadership and on the cowardice of like
you know some of the some of the
officers who had just let order break
down he did not accept that he had lost
that war and he thought we were afraid
to go after him
and it is kind of strange when you think
about it
how quickly they broke down because
here's what you'd think and like wait
you just got out of an eight-year war
with iran you are hardened combat
soldiers
that's very strange i wouldn't have
predicted that you know i
some sometimes i talk about the fact
that i don't bet on the ufc
you know the ultimate fighting
championship i don't bet on the ufc
and the reason why is because there have
been
i'll say about 10 times
in my i've been following the ufc since
it started there's been about 10 times
where i knew i had inside information
like you know because i'm friends and
training partners and training with
people and training with people that
were about to fight
i had inside information where
i would have easily said oh i'll bet
the house i'll bet my you know i'll bet
next year's paychecks
that this guy is going to win and sure
enough i'd lose i would have lost
and i i realized you know there's been a
couple times where i had good inside
information played out just the way i
thought it would
but as joe rogan says it's a fight yeah
and anything can happen in a fight so if
you were to tell me
and i'm trying to look i'm trying not to
be not trying not to use the benefit of
hindsight because it's real easy to look
back of course we've got the
technological power and even when you
just i
i threw that out that little arrogant
quote when you're like they didn't think
they could beat us technically and i
said watch this
you know i'm sitting here saying that if
you would
ask me knowing what i know now
hey uh who's gonna win or what kind of
scrap
is this gonna be you've got eight years
worth of
hardened combat veterans on the iraqi
side
versus and by the way they're fighting
in their home
like turf versus these americans the
last thing we did
on a large scale was vietnam which
we didn't like you know we didn't like
that
and now we're going toe-to-toe with
these guys that's a much tougher thing
to think about and yeah i mean we think
about the generals at this time
all those generals vast majority of
these generals were
vietnam guys that were looking at this
thing going okay i'll go but
we better be hit them with overwhelming
force
but yeah i've never really thought that
deeply about it the fact
that this was not a this is not a given
and it ended up the fact that it was so
easy which is exactly what it was and
i'm curious
i mean the the the iraqi soldiers just
fell apart fell apart and ran yeah it
was like
it's kind of crazy to think about why
would you why didn't you fall apart and
run from
the iranians our biggest problem early
on those first few days of the assault
became processing all the pows who were
surrendering we were like we don't
really have the manpower to deal with
all these people
i think part of it was that you know
just in that massive choreographed
airstrike at the beginning we took out
all of their air defense all of their
communications and just their whole
everything that linked their military
structure together just went dark
and so every little unit that's spread
around is now just out there on their
own basically
they got to send runners if they want to
talk to somebody and then the first
marines
just rampages straight at them
and and to your point you know this is
uh you know
this is the this is centralized command
right this is this is not a bunch of
hey i got cut off from my unit but i
know what the objective is and i'm going
to carry it out regardless
that's not the iraqi army the iraqi army
is i'm not doing a damn thing
most arab armies are like yeah yeah i'm
not doing a damn thing
until i get told exactly what to do
because i'm not going to get
even still it is crazy when you think
about the fact that those juniors and
colonel or generals and colonels and
stuff they knew that if their unit just
decided to surrender
that it's going to be bad news for them
and yet that's what happened in
mass masters yeah it's it's hard to
understand the psychology behind that
yeah
actually and it taught us some you know
we learned some negative lessons from
that as well
well yeah we absolutely learned some
negative lessons from that
although i i
i don't know right i mean let's face it
the the opening
the opening um salvos of
of the invasion in 2003 yeah were pretty
much the same thing
i mean pretty much the same thing there
was some there was there was
more resistance obviously as we pushed
up i mean and again i just had a guy on
gunny buster who was
um who was on the push-up you know
nazaria there was a little hesitation
there was some some fighting but
it was vastly massive
surrender yeah i mean the american
military is
it's something that's never been seen
before i mean and even if you take the
technology out of it when you put the
just the communications and coordination
the multi-force
coordination um you know it's crazy to
me
i used to play uh paintball a lot with
my friends and we would go play
paintball
and we were all fast we were athletes we
went you know whatever and we'd go out
and play
and we would sometimes run into these
fat old guys who had been playing
together for a long time who just knew
how to move they knew how to work
together
cover and move and all that kind of
stuff and they would just
butcher us and it's insane how how much
of a difference
just knowing what you're doing really
makes and uh i i
how how many times do you read about
like you know um
ranger unit in uh afghanistan ambushed
by
the taliban one ranger wounded 32
taliban killed you know 52
like captured and it's like wait i get
that we have stealth bombers and
satellites and all that but like this is
still just dudes with guns right
it's like well yeah yeah and no i mean
american military is a buzz saw
that you just you know feed human beings
into when it gets worked up
and uh but i think what i meant was it
kind of gave us this lesson that like
man not only is war easy
yes it's uh it's kind of it's
politically uniting
you know you remember back back in the
early 90s there was that music video
voices that care it was like every huge
celebrity
the biggest people i mean it was bono
and will smith and
i actually don't remember this at all it
was it would be the equivalent of today
of like katy perry
and taylor swift what was it uh like a
music video pro troops or something yeah
it was just saying to the troops voices
that care we're thinking about you while
you're over there something you could
not
imagine seeing today it's just a
different environment it was probably a
boot camp or something because i
do not remember that at all you got to
watch it just for the different times
because today it would be hard to
imagine anything like that and
especially from that class of people
um and it was so is politically unifying
you know it was kind of we didn't lose
much of anybody
you know we uh behaved ourselves very
very
honorably you know um yes you are
then i then i accept your assessment
that some bad lessons were learned
not so much about yeah about
about uh we we learned the lesson that
this was going to be easy and then
kosovo reinforced that
yeah kosovo reinforced that and all
those people that said
you need boots on the ground in order to
really
affect change well we went to kosovo and
no boots on the ground exactly
and you look up and you go well there
were also intelligence like lessons that
we
you know the all the military all the
military guys who were hesitant at first
you had a lot of the civilian leadership
who was looking at them like they were
just kind of
too cautious a little too scared a
little too shocked by vietnam
you know those experiences so that when
we got up to 2003
you had a lot of the military side
saying look we got
this is not enough people to secure this
country we need 300 000 we need 400 000
people we need this we need that
and you know a lot of these same guys in
the bush administration
were the same guys in lower level
mid-level positions in the first bush
administration they're like wait i've
heard this before from
people in fact colin powell who's
secretary of state now who's the one
who's telling us to be very very careful
here if we're going to go into iraq
i've heard this from you before you were
cautious in the first gulf war as well
and so you know there was a little bit
of uh a little
bit of distrust between the civilian and
military leadership that came in
ah that's really um really
disturbing but it's such a no it's like
as
you as you talk about it's just like oh
yeah i mean i see this all the time
right i see this all the time from
businesses from leaders that they don't
have a good enough relationship they
don't communicate to each other properly
they don't explain things in a way that
could be clear and instead of explaining
they just get mad and they say
you know i'm telling you you got to
trust me and like that that all that's
all that is it's it's it's awful
it's awful yeah yeah and um
you know i think that uh you know the
intelligence side as well
you know this no our intelligence did
not see the invasion of kuwait coming it
caught us off guard
and so you you know some of the civilian
leadership lost trust
with the intelligence community there
when 911 surprised us again a lot of
those same people
come to distrust you know some of the
intelligence establishment even more
and it was a little bit of a toxic
relationship by the time you got 2003
between you know the the brass at the
dod and some of these other places
and the actual military leadership and
the intelligence community leadership
that i think you know there were we'll
get into that then maybe the next uh
episode or so
that you know there there were some
breakdowns in communication at the
leadership level that
that ended up filtering down to you guys
on the ground and that's what i'm kind
of interested in hearing about
is there anything else to to wrap up
kind of
pre-pre like escalation of tensions
leading into
into uh the invasion in o3
i think we can probably uh
talk a little bit about it in the next
episode um we'll
talk about how we kind of started that
ball rolling after 9 11.
and i want to talk a little bit about
what iraq was up to in the 90s as well
and how we were dealing with them and
how it had become this kind of festering
soar
that we did not have a good solution for
you know that it was just sitting there
because of the oil for food program and
because of the way the sanctions were
being cheated by a lot of countries
in the most corrupt and ugliest ways you
know just
saddam's regime is you know letting a
lot of these countries
you know just full corruption take cuts
from like the oil for food
uh sales and then they're feeding
billions of dollars back to saddam's
regime
ugly stuff by people who are supposed to
be our allies
and uh so you know it creates a
situation where you
you have this regime who's there who's
ruling through brutality and terror
who's not going anywhere the sanctions
are not going to work and
children are dying of starvation in the
streets because of the sanctions
so a lot of people are starting to say
we can't keep this up we can't just
start keep starving this population
well okay what are you what are you
gonna do you're gonna say oh saddam
you got us all those u.n resolutions
all none of that means that you won you
outlasted us you outlasted the global
community
right the global order with all these
institutions behind it you just you beat
us you outlasted us because you were
willing to
inflict such suffering on your own
people to watch them starve while you
and your regime took all the money that
you were getting
and used it to control them and we just
can't take watching this anymore so
you know we're just going to lift all
this and you admit you won
and create that precedent for other
people like you going forward
or you know in a post-9 11 world we can
go in there and do something about it
and that was really you know the second
iraq war if you want to put it that way
is a lot of people and i think history
will bear this out
it wasn't a second war there were there
were uh
you know two uh ground fights
two you know uh moments of acute combat
in one long war with saddam hussein's
regime
we were launching airstrikes at him all
through the 1990s
in 1993 he tried to assassinate george
h.w
bush this is after he's pre he's not
even president anymore and he was
visiting kuwait and saddam sent a hit
team
over there to try to assassinate him you
know a former american president
and so this guy is not cowed you know he
is still causing problems for us
and meanwhile iran is growing and
becoming more dangerous
and you know we we need a functional
iraq if you look at a map of the middle
east it is just right there
in the middle of everything and we need
it to be somewhat functional
but we can't help it be functional as
long as this guy's in control
because we can't build him up and so
what do you do
and um people are going to be debating
you know
long after we get done with this uh that
what the right thing to do what there
was but i think people oversimplify what
our options were
yeah and again it's well two things one
thing i want to correct is i said that a
guy that i had in the podcast
was in the first goal for and i actually
i was in my mind i was thinking but no
he was on the push-up
but he had guys that had been in the
first goal for that kind of
they they helped them along and and then
i'm thinking about this and again
just to frame this up you know some
people say that i'm like a driven
person right and and you know and i
i i am you know there's i i want to do
things and i want to
you know i i when somebody says you know
what's your goal i'll be like take over
the world right
ha ha fun fun like yeah there's some
there's a hint of truth in there because
i want to
go out and make things happen but you
know i'm not looking to take over the
world
in a literal sense
and then you think about saddam and you
and you like so i'm thinking about it
from my perspective as you're talking
through all this stuff i'm thinking you
know
i like to you know as i was reflecting
back on what i told you earlier is like
hey aren't you good
like you've got a country you've taken
over
you got billions of dollars worth of
assets
you fought a long war like
even me i think i'd look around and be
like all right
you know what i'll i'll go ahead and
we'll just call this
success i've got my own nation
i've got billions of dollars
i'll call it good but it's not good
enough
there's actually there is one thing that
we did uh leave out we talked about a
little bit earlier but
um is that after the war is over
on his way out out of spite he lights up
all the kuwaiti oil wells just to black
in the sky
creates the biggest oil spill in human
history by opening up the valves
in kuwait and sending it out into the
into the persian gulf
and then and this is really where you
got a lot of people who were
after 9 11 really really really
looking for saddam's throat in the
united states um
is we had told the people of iraq
meaning sort of the shia population in
the south the kurds in the north
rise up against saddam hussein you know
yeah that's right we thought that
he would be overthrown in kind of a
natural way we were also talking to his
generals and whoever else but
we may you know that wasn't going to
happen the sunni population wasn't going
to turn on him
to hand over control to the shiites you
know that's not going to happen so we're
talking to the shia population in the
south the kurds in the north rise up
against saddam and they do and
we just watch from across the border as
he annihilates them
you know kills we don't actually know
maybe 180
000 people all told but for sure a
hundred thousand
and we are right across the border in
kuwait
easily with the ability to stop it from
happening to the shiites he drives
i mean scores of thousands of kurds this
is what you were reading about earlier
up into the mountains
this is in january and february they're
going to freeze to death they're going
to starve to death he's massacring these
people using
human women and children as human
shields as he goes into their villages
threatening using them as hostages
saying i'm going to kill these women and
children if the men don't stay put they
stay put he masters all the men
and so all these kurds flee up into the
mountains
and we have junior you know
state department defense department uh
officials at the time guys like paul
wolfowitz
who would be donald rumsfeld's deputy by
the time we get to 2003 who were like if
i get another crack at this guy
i am taking him out and um
because they felt like we betrayed those
people and we did
you know um and of course we went in
to help the kurds afterwards you know as
they were getting pushed out operation
provide comfort we start dropping
supplies to them and it starts out as
that but then we're like what are we
going to do with these people
and turkey's like you're not keeping
kurds here right and so we're like well
we people were worried that if we set
them up in like a uh you know in a
refugee camp somewhere
that it would turn into another
palestinian situation so finally we were
like let's just
push the iraqi army back far enough so
these people can go back to their homes
and so
we did that and the kurds moved in back
to their homes and we were like well now
we kind of inherited the responsibility
to protect these people and we did that
and it was awesome was it southern watch
that was operation southern watch
yeah and uh um i don't remember actually
i don't remember
um i don't i thought it was a part of
provide comfort like yeah it might have
been perfect provide comfort and provide
comfort too
and it was amazing it worked perfectly
like the kurds created
one of the best places in the middle
east besides israel i mean just a great
place up there in rebel
considering the neighborhood and that
was another
lesson that we took that like oh okay if
we can just go in there and get rid of
the bad
people then the good people can come in
and just build up a nice little
society it's that idea of if i can just
if we can just tip the scales
right if we can just tip the scales and
i i i don't know where i originally
heard this from but it was
somebody that had direct relations
with uh cuba like someone that was cuban
or parents were cuban and had been
passed down this lore
which was when all the cubans in america
were saying hey look all we need to do
is start this thing off
and the p you know everyone the cubans
will rebel against fidel castro and will
free cuba and you know the story was it
was like
all the cubans that were saying that and
all the cubans
and it was a lot of humans that were
saying that all of them that were saying
that were in america
and so they're saying yeah don't worry
and as soon as they got down there the
cubans that were in cuba were like what
are you doing
no this is cuba we don't want you here
and
it's not quite the same situation but
the idea that you can tip the scales
the idea that just gonna take a little
bit to tip the scales is is the the
feeling that you get when you're
on the outside looking in and it looks
like
hey if we just apply enough pressure
here there's
they can rise up against them and yet
that is all true and yet i think that
and we'll get into this
we'll talk about some of those bad
decisions we started to talk about
in the last episode up that when we went
in in 2003
that was a winnable fight and it was
winnable early i think i really do
i think it was something that it would
have taken a long time you know it would
have taken some
some dedication as far as timeline went
some presence
but um i think that uh that what that
war turned into had a lot to do with
decisions that that we made once we were
there
there's no doubt about it and i guess we
can get on those get into those
decisions
in that war next time so
if you want to support this podcast
check out our other podcasts
i have jocko podcasts the warrior kid
podcast and the grounded podcast and
daryl's got a pad
podcast called margaret made and if you
want to support
all these podcasts then one thing you
can do to help out is
go and get some gear from jockostore.com
or get some gear from origin main.com
got all kinds of stuff on there thanks
for listening
as things unravel
this is jocko and daryl out